allora ragazzi è successo per chi non lo
sapesse che io e ciccio gay non ci siamo
lanciati delle frecciatine
insomma la cosa andata un po oltre
quanto io mi aspettarsi perché alla fine
sta cosa ha avuto una risonanza
incredibile sul web ci sono uscire un
miliardo di video cosa è successo è
successo che cc dei meri in un video ha
detto da volo su grado e fa vincere la
vigenza solo gli iscritti più da me ma
non contano più un cazzo questa cosa
secondo me è sbagliata a prescindere nel
senso che ma anche fosse vera come cosa
per comunque un punto di vista che il
suo non l'ho vista come un uscita umile
mettiamola così e quindi mi sono un po
girate le palle a prescindere dal fatto
che fosse vero no perché secondo me non
è manco vero quello che ha detto però
lasciamo perdere il vero non è vero chi
se ne frega io quando ho sentito questa
cosa perché l'ho sentita tipo la
settimana scorsa ho risposte in un video
dando la mia frecciatina risposto a
ciccio gamer che ho detto questa cosa
qua dovrei forse fare un video di
risposta alle cazzate che spara su di me
ciccio gain e per fare più facili oppure
potrei piangere davanti alla videocamera
come ha fatto lui
questo che ho detto in risposta alla
frecciatina che aveva mandato ciccio
canale su youtube esploso il mondo
quindi che cosa e su cosa ho deciso di
fare cosa abbiamo deciso di fare da
persone un po più mature di risolvere la
questione in privato perché ci siamo poi
sentiti e adesso che abbiamo risolto la
situazione abbia deciso di fare un video
insieme io e ciccio dove spieghiamo un
pochettino come è andata la questione in
modo da chiudere definitivamente il
cerchio
buona visione ragazzi quindi ragazzi se
non su rocket e siamo con il mio più
acerrimo nemico questo punto come batman
perfette gioca no perché tuo fratello
però vabbè batman il pinguino perché
abbiamo deciso di fare un video visto
che le cose stanno leggermente sfuggendo
di mano quindi oggi giochiamo al rocket
league
un pochettino cds leggiamo io faccio
pagare quanto ma anche io faccio kakà
fidati equilibrati sono altri però
almeno parliamo di questa cosa giocando
su roche 22 p2 e cerchiamo la partita ed
allora mentre vinciamo oggi ci aveva
difficoltà motoria che fosse mai fatto
incredibile mentre la giochiamo
la difficoltà aggiuntiva e che dobbiamo
parlare di quella cosa lì non solo ti
devi impegnare a giocare devi anche
parlati qualche successo impegnati pure
di guerra e allora dico io ma rowe che
il video è mio partner e allora io un
giorno mi sveglio tipo come dovrei fare
adesso mi sveglia e vedo quel video è
l'app quello magnifico che occupavano il
pezzettino li sento ho superato gabos
superato va vj poi già un sacco di
iscritti di iscritti non contano un
cazzo
io ho sentito questa cosa è lì per lì ho
detto oh ma ciccio si è drogato
fortissimo o l'hanno obbligato di lucera
power che diceva una pistola sotto la
sedia e lui ha puntato addosso e non
capivo quindi ti ho scritto whatsapp at
the town ma che è il messaggio che
arrivava sul telefono ho detto ammazzo
questo ma pure bloccato detto bommassar
al successo qualcosa quindi io non ti
arriva neanche il messaggio penso che mi
avessi bloccato su whatsapp capito
spiega il parroco
molto bene e allora ho detto o non
capisco perchè non avevo più il contatto
detto mai niente cioè senza successo
qualcosa
poi però ho detto vabbè sticazzi di
quello che è successo dopo due giorni
comunque la gente continuava a scrivermi
starò mai visto del di singh che ha
fatto ci ha visto questa roba deciso del
sì l'ho visto l'ho visto dopo un po
caccia in te mi rompere le balle
alcuni miei amici mi ha detto perchè non
fai un video di risposta sta cosa visto
che stava già crescendo di suo e ho
detto vabbè facciamo un video di
risposta io ti ho fatto un video di
risposta lunghissimo che durava tipo 12
minuti e non l'ho mai caricato che era
molto più pesante di quel micro dissing
che tutti hanno visto alla fine dove ho
detto era veramente pesantissimo
confrontavo statistiche cose assurde e
poi l'ho riguardato detto no vabbè
sentire io non ce la faccio a farlo
perché comunque uno conosco ciccio al
anche se ha detto raro bara mi dispiace
lo stesso fa ambito del genere prima e
seconda cosa ho detto
conoscendola per tipo di persona che non
si merita un video del genere a loro ho
limitato la cosa a quel microscopico
dissing se così vogliamo chiamarlo che è
quello che hanno visto tutti è un niente
da quello si è generato l'inferno
quindi volevo solo semplicemente
spiegare il fatto che non abbiamo
segnato primo che ci siamo chiariti
perché ci siamo chiariti una persona
privato e poi volevo senti un attimo
come è andata la tua visto che tu hai
parlato con 14p non spiega minato
momento molto molto più semplice e molto
meno articolato di quello che possa
sembrare praticamente io
l'idea e condivi possono condividere o
non condividere che in questo momento
anzi da un bel po di tempo gli iscritti
come inteso numero punto e basta a mio
avviso non contano più
perché potevano contare una volta adesso
li scritto non è più un indice di
qualità o un indice di
di essere seguito eccetera eccetera e
quindi la roba molto aspetta no non ci
credo ho preso la traversa
poiché la cassetta family concentra un
attimo non ci credo ho preso la traversa
che brucia non ci credo questa non ci
meritiamo noi ci meritiamo li perdo da
teloni neri taglio non ci meritiamo di
perderla questa titoli da rob era molto
più tranquilla non volevo molto chiaro
non vuole molto
però io io siccome sulla cosa degli
script per chi quanto quali ha detto gli
iscritti non contano un cazzo perché non
sono più indice di gente che ti seguono
perché ci sono un sacco anche gli
iscritti inattivi però la cosa che tu
hai detto era molto limitato rya nel
senso che non contano un cazzo non sa
più interpretare in un miliardo e mezzo
di modica viso quindi io l'ho
interpretata della serie c agli iscritti
ma gli iscritti non contano un cazzo
della serie domin chiavari con gli
iscritti da soli istituti portano ma no
ma non era riferito nello spiega mi dico
a te non è che io ho messo in mezzo de
perché sei un punto di riferimento della
community italiana come modello posso
essere io come può esserlo qualsiasi
altro youtuber grande no cioè il
discorso se ci sei capitato tu ma non
era riferito nello specifico a te chiaro
perché ho fatto tutto un discorso della
serie perché io nella mia testa era
entrato della selezione detto gli
scritti non contano un cazzo perché
pensavo inconsciamente che tu avessi
detto va uno fa a 15 milioni iscritti
però a 100.000 chiuso a video che sono
niente in quanto 5.000 iscritti quindi
in quel senso di iscritti non conta ma
generalmente adesso che hanno altri ci
sono altri che bella stampa ci sono
altre al seguito quando fai un film a
cose o quando fai un libro e sarà quando
senso ma ci sono altre
altri metodi di valutazione rispetto al
semplice iscritto sino ai dici che senti
versamento dolori al in prima cerea
prima era importantissima l'iscritto no
ti ricordi quando eravamo piccoli
piccoli rete 100 cv 100 km 105 mila me
lo ricordo perfettamente tua confronto
mio animo il suo più grande invece
adesso magari ci sono canali seppur
virali in questo momento che veramente
via torta non ci hanno neanche un decimo
che non si iscritti che però sono
conosciuti attualmente quanto noi capito
era una sorta di gioco del momento o
semplicemente perché fanno video di sing
o video un cerchio cioè tutte se
puttanate quano già così è molto più
articolata comunque la faccenda è molto
per dire perché quella vuole essere un
intervista tranquilla serena senza
andare troppo nel dettaglio e poi non ho
detto che la mia parola e la parola di
un santone la parola di uno che se dice
qualcosa deve essere per forza vera
infatti ho detto più di una volta porca
vacca 11 ho detto più di una volta
secondo me al mio punto di vista che poi
potete sì che poi magari dal video che
ho visto io erano pure tagliati stipendi
molti di quelli che ci seguono hanno
detto il tuo errore è stato quello di
vedere i pezzi montati perché perché lo
sai che su youtube o generale alla gente
interessa il di singh boyle issing sia
solo quello bravo ciccio esatto che non
sono abituato a queste cose che non
pensa abbiamo trattato di e power brani
grazie comunque una cosa per per
concludere invece questa la mia parte
che non l'ho detto io siccome non avevo
idea di che cosa dire per cercare un
dissing che fosse slim marche lo stesso
tempo facesse un minimo di effetto ho
detto quella roba delle olive dice
cazzate su di me e poi ho detto quella
cosa del forse dovrei piangere per fare
più bus nei video come ha fatto lui
questa cosa qua che io mi sono permesso
di dire questa cosa del genere per
un'unica motivazione perché io ti
conosco come persona e so che tu su ste
cose qua se in molto più avanti di un
fosse stato ragazzino di 16 anni non
avrei mai detto una cagata così perché
so che magari un ragazzino sta roba se
la prende io conoscendoti proprio di
persona ho detto sicuramente se lui
sente una roba del genere più che una
risata non sa può fare veramente è
gravissimo io l'ho capito io l'ho capito
c'è gente che non l'ho capita non l'ha
capito certe che non lo capisce e
infatti io lo dico molto spesso che i
problemi crea in realtà la gente da noi
dall'altra porta ci va bene no quasi 9
dai tracciati sempre e io posso averlo
capito ma poi vedi pure la gente tra
l'altro è un po maligna perché sono
venuti a te dicendo hai riso ciccio da
addossato tu sei andato un range non c'è
miss previsto un pezzo da jato e hai
agito di conseguenza certo capito è
sempre la community che la fa molto più
grossa lima per far ma non è senza senza
cattiveria o senza dar colpa nello
specifico semplicemente perché non gli
piace così gli piace la fine va bene
così a loro ci ho provato a farla da ci
sono riuscito va bene è niente quindi in
conclusione noi siamo amici come prima
tutto a posto perché poi tra l'altro una
cosa che non si capisce che ormai la
gente abituata
non ci credo che hai fatto una cosa così
hai fatto la cosa incredibile se andata
a recuperare palla dalla e spinto la è
dotata del bravissimo bravissima
complimenti e l'abbiamo pure vinta c è
un segno di più che altro nel video che
vedete penso su entrambi i canali perché
vogliamo far capire veramente che frame
e lorenzo non c'è niente dice nulla
corrotto anzi ripetono lorenzo se penso
siamo gli unici due youtuber che si sono
incontrati in meno io e te non è che
abbiamo parlato chissà quanto fiera o
c'erano avuto almeno rapporto è ma è che
però ci siamo sempre trovati bene
abbiamo collaborato un botto io e tempo
e cioè abbiamo fatto un sacco di cose
belle e continueremo a farle
stiamo parlando del denim entrati ma
continuerà magari fra due mesi lorenzo
ne sparano altra frecciatina io la
rispar a lui ma a volo sicuro di mapello
va bene spero sia chiaro per tutti
bella per tutti bene per ciccio che
qualcuno più forte di rompersi culo
supportare i ragazzi che sarà mio video
con ciccio spero che le cose si siano
chiarite per voi più che altro non più
che per noi deponete i sonagli che è
tutto a posto quindi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come di servire più l'argomento
vi piace anche a vari sociale che
comitato atene descrizione sera sera per
si schieri e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo di sting bella ragazza
[Musica]